[Music]
anyone who can get out get out right now
do not look up do not make eye contact
him just go Li stay calm I'm right here
[Applause]
we are live in five minutes you have
their revisions for the O's still making
some change
am I gonna get the changes before the
show or at know the gym you just point
the camera in my direction we'll figure
it out together always sound so simple
and yet so moronic Gary is the Wizard of
Wall Street himself the name is Lee
Gates the show is money monster without
risk there is no reward
should I sell should I unload man up
who's that guy on camera two what I can
play about it go ahead who is it anybody
knows what is a union thing whoever's in
there 20 cameras online at Amazon Patti
[Music]
take it out put it on I know will blow
off is I have the detonator mic thumb
comes off this trigger and we all
explode I might be the one with the gun
here and I'm not the real criminals
people like these guys I've got my
finger on the trigger I'm telling you
it's rigged the whole game thing but I
don't true they're stealing everything
from us and they're getting away with it
too they were fair just keep talking to
him all right you're good at that
got enough finger on the trigger you
lost a lot of money when the market and
they just they track down his girlfriend
that was everything we had every my sect
for you Joe
I'll get you some answers nobody was
asking any questions before these guys
could expose everything we both want an
explanation for what went wrong we don't
know you have to understand her delicate
of a situation they're talking about
delicate situations
we're human beings are not computers we
are conscious
I'm trying to save her
you're trying to shoot them I want an
explanation follow the money find the
fraud bring this together now come turn
your back on anybody I don't want you to
die
you came here to get some answers you
deserve to get some answers years ago
ancient being was born the world's first
Newton you are all
and